[Musique]
et avec nous pour ce grand débat 3
sénateurs merci beaucoup de nous avoir
rejoint Christine Lavarde bonjour
bonjour merci d'être là c'est matrice
les républicains des Hauts-de-Seine tout
juste réélu hier soir félicitations
Christine lavard Patrick canard
président du groupe socialiste du Sénat
tout juste élu également sénateur du
Nord félicitations également et François
Patriat vous n'étiez pas renouvelable
sénateur de la Côte d'Or
de la majorité présidentielle bonjour
François Patriat merci également d'être
avec nous avec nous dans quelques
instants depuis le Pas-de-Calais
Christophe Zurich elle sera là il fait
partie des trois sénateurs nouvellement
élus du rassemblement national on va
évidemment parler du résultat de ce
scrutin mais difficile en parlant de la
soirée d'hier soir de ne pas dire un mot
d'Emmanuel Macron et de cette interview
le chef de l'État qui s'est invité dans
les 20 heures le soir des sénatoriales
comment vous jugez Saint-Patrick c'est
une première bon mais
de la République est disruptif c'est un
mot qui notamment au début du
quinquennat précédent moi moi je le
regrette parce que c'est un moment
politique important au moment
démocratique important même si fragile
universel indirect on aurait pu imaginer
que le Président de la République je
dirais s'applique la règle de réserve
qu'il appliquait assez collaborateur
nationaux et locaux voilà et en plus
pour nous dire beaucoup trop de choses
d'ailleurs certains ont eu du mal à
comprendre exactement tout ce qu'il
voulait nous passer comme message mais
sur la forme je le regrette parce que je
crois que le Président de la République
doit laisser la procédure à les jusqu'au
bout et on aurait pu imaginer qu'il
interviennent aujourd'hui ça aurait été
plus simple
à mes complètement surtout qu'on parle
quand même d'un sujet d'extrêmement
grande importance alors je sais pas si
c'était pour griller la priorité à la
première ministre au ministre en charge
du dossier qui vont parler de ce grand
sujet de la planification écologique
mais je pense qu'au final les
spectateurs ou téléspectateurs n'ont pas
forcément compris grand-chose et
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans les retours
presse il y a un juste équilibre entre
le résultat des élections sénatoriales
et la locution du président de la
République donc je pense qu'il en sort
absolument pas gagnant et effectivement
en plus on a parlé de tellement de
choses que à la fin on retient pas trop
une idée claire de ce que le chemin que
va prendre cette planification
écologique François Patriat pourquoi ce
soir-là en plus il a parlé des
sénatoriales en parlant en félicitant le
tiers de ces sénateurs et élus ces fois
c'est c'est une méconnaissance du Sénat
alors une fois de plus je vais être sur
le contre tous j'ai compris c'est mon
rôle dans cette maison je m'y plaît je
le fais avec détermination d'abord je
pense que il faut comprendre que nous
vivons actuellement sur une poudrière
avec des sujets essentiels qui
concernent les Français auxquels les
Français s'intéressent
j'entends bien
l'importance de l'élection sénatoriale
hier on a participé à la soirée on fait
la campagne avec nos amis souvent
difficile pour ce qui nous concerne et
les Français je pense sont plus
préoccupés par les problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui d'autres que par les
élections sénatoriales on peut le
déplorer mais c'est plutôt comme ça que
le président s'exprime hier soir il y
avait des sujets il y avait le prix que
le carburant sont devenus ça s'inviter
le problème du Niger le problème de la
planification écologique pour demain qui
va commencer on va parler cette semaine
budget et on va parler planification
écologique c'est deux sujets essentiels
sur lesquels la première ministre va
s'expliquer mais que le Président de la
République est souhaitait s'adresser aux
Français tout quand il y a pas une forme
de mépris pour le Sénat de pas respecter
le soir des élections sénatoriales à
chaque fois que les problématique que
j'entends parler au sujet de chez de
l'état de névri c'est un mot qui est
devenu un peu à la mode d'un moment je
connais un peu le chef de l'État je peux
vous assurer c'est que à la fois dans sa
fonction dans sa vision des Français et
ça fonctionne et absolument
du Sénat pas du tout vous savez il a été
élu à 39 ans de la République moi
j'aurais bien été incapable
pour une fois je vais partager ce que
dit
ça va les tonner non mais il y a pas de
mépris effectivement de la part de
du président de la République je crois
qu'ils s'en fout je crois qu'ils s'en
fout et qu'il est voilà il est dans sa
ligne Jupiter voilà il est président
Premier ministre ministre on l'a vu sur
l'éducation il a remplacé de fait le son
ministre nouvellement nommé Gabriel
Attal donc voilà c'est à c'est un mode
de fonctionnement très personnel il
fatigue tu crois pas
il connaissait les institutions et il
est respecté profondément parce que il
avait été membre de chacune de ces
institutions je pense que ça tu peux pas
nous le retirer collectivement puisque
tu étais avec moi sans soutien dans ce
cas là
mais je vais vous donner un autre
exemple qui est bien plus inclus
inquiétant
Dominique fort ministre en charge de
collectivités locales qui annonce fin
août à 5 semaines des élections
sénatoriales qu'il faut augmenter les
indemnités des élus de 3500 à 100000
habitants alors que voilà on est rentré
dans une campagne enfin c'est quoi son
achète les voix et cela n'a pas marché
malheureusement pour nos amis du RPI
honnêtement il y a des choses qui ne
vont pas moi je le regrette le Sénat
doit être respecté dans sa composition
et sa diversité un mot juste sur une des
annonces du chef de l'État Christine
Labarde vous suivez particulièrement les
sujets de financier sujet budgétaire ici
au Sénat c'est la vente à perte
Elisabeth borne avait annoncé que les
distributeurs de carburant serait
autorisés avant grappert finalement le
chef de l'État a reculé ce ne sera pas
inscrit dans le projet de loi c'est une
bonne nouvelle ou pas ah mais alors là
c'est une excellente nouvelle parce que
déjà ce sujet posé la question de
l'égalité de traitement entre ceux qui
peuvent supporter des pertes parce qu'il
les mutualise avec le reste de leur
activité économique et ceux qui
n'auraient pas pu le faire typiquement
les pompistes indépendants qui sont très
utiles en zone rurale en zone de
montagne parce que s'ils ne sont pas là
la mobilité se trouve fortement
contraint de voir réduite et en plus
parce que c'était de nouveau une
politique du quad qu'il en coûte les
yeux fermés on est des tout le monde de
la même manière aussi bien ceux qui se
déplacent pour le loisir que ceux qui se
déplacent parce que sans leur voiture
ils ne pourraient pas continuer à aller
travailler donc c'était vraiment une
politique qui n'avait aucun
qui n'était pas raisonnable au regard de
notre endettement au regard de la
trajectoire de nos finances publiques
donc là avec l'annonce d'un nouveau
chèque carburant alors c'est encore la
politique du chèque je croyais qu'on
avait quitté le quoiqu'il en coûte
effectivement c'est peut-être un peu
plus du combien ça coûte mais en tout
cas ça sera une politique ciblée alors
là cette fois-ci elle est ciblée un peu
large puisque j'ai cru comprendre qu'il
s'agirait des cinq premiers défiles
le roi du chèque a parlé voilà il faut
s'y habituer là aussi depuis longtemps
ce que veulent les Français c'est pas
d'échec ils veulent pas l'aumône qui
veulent c'est un pouvoir d'achat
augmenter il faut vraiment qu'on ait
cette conférence sociale que nous avons
des arrachés lors de cette fameuse
rencontre à secrète avec les chefs de
parti il faut augmenter cela il faut
sûrement baisser de manière durable la
fiscalité tant que le prix du baril ne
redescende pas ça c'est ça la vraie
question parce que pourquoi choisir
telle personne moi je connais des
retraités des maires retraités que j'ai
vu pendant cette campagne il y a
quelques jours et qui prennent très
souvent leur voiture parce que le
village est très grand ils sont obligés
de prendre la voiture il y a pas de
moyen de transport pourquoi cela ne
pourrait pas avoir ce chèque alors
qu'ils ont un tout petit salaire enfin
une petite indemnité de rien du tout
donc c'est très compliqué très compliqué
à mettre en oeuvre sûrement des gens qui
ne devraient pas la voir vont la voir
tant mieux pour eux entre guillemets
d'autres ne l'auront pas on ne comprend
pas cette politique du chèque et surtout
sur la forme surtout sur la forme madame
bornannonce la mesure qui est décrié que
je j'ai vraiment je la condamne aussi
comme vient de le faire même la barbe
donc vous êtes content qu'elle sortirait
je suis mais annoncer une telle mesure
sans avoir pris la précaution d'avoir
consulté préalablement les fournisseurs
de pétrole mais mais c'est pas assez de
la batterie c'est de la batterie
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
d'abord le président de la République
prend acte du fait que les grands
distributeurs les raffineurs ne
souhaitent pas le faire et qui aura une
opposition qui on le fera pas quoi nous
avons pas compte de
deuxièmement parce qu'il fallait essayer
de te lancer la faire puis on peut pas
d'un côté comme vous le faites tous vous
le voir taxer les super profits et le
jour où on demande pétrolier dans le
même temps et faire un de faire un
effort de faire un effort de de le
reprocher alors c'est pas toujours le
chèque quand même si vous avez un
chiffre pour 2022 2023 le prix du
bouclier le bouclier pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas un chèque c'est pas
monsieur chèque c'est 90 milliards que
l'État a pris sur le budget et que
parfois la majorité du Sénat nous
reproche parce que l'on peut pas d'un
côté dire il faut aider les plus démunis
il faut vraiment aider mieux les
collectivités il faut vraiment faire
plus dans telle ou tel domaine dans la
police dans la justice dans l'école
partout et le jour où le gouvernement
dit vous savez les taxes sur le
carburant elle servent à quoi elles vont
se servir à 50% pour la transition
écologique à 50% pour la social il y a
50% pour le pouvoir à 25% pour le pour
les chercheuses pour la sécurité sociale
et puis à 25% pour le pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire on peut
pas vouloir tout et son contraire je
crois que les choix sont difficiles ce
qui ont exercé des responsabilités vous
en avez exercé Patrick en a exercé sa
vie aujourd'hui que c'est pas si facile
que ça qu'il faut toujours naviguer
entre plusieurs options présidents a
priacte la décision il le fait
aujourd'hui
on va parler du résultat des
sénatoriales aller en fait lié
d'ailleurs à la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron vous nous le direz pour votre
groupe dans quelques instants François
Patriat d'abord Patrick annère est-ce
que ce matin vous y voyez plus clair sur
la composition de votre groupe combien
vous aurez de sénateurs est-ce que vous
en gagnez nous étions 64 hier matin nous
sommes au moins 64 aujourd'hui parce que
vous savez que les sénateurs élus que je
félicite dans leur diversité sauf trois
d'entre eux
oui les trois RN enfin je ne fais
peut-être pas voilà je vais les combats
mais les autres républus de manière très
plus Ken je les salue je les félicite
mais ils ont jusqu'au 3 octobre sauf de
ma part pour pouvoir s'inscrire dans un
groupe et donc il y a des divers gauche
qui ont été élus hier et peut-être que
nous allons passer cette barre de 64 je
suis très content de cette stabilité je
pense que nous allons progresser que
globalement l'objectif que je m'étais
fixé avec mes collègues assassis et
Gontard de sang partout voilà une barre
de sang c'est la terre de gauche devrait
être tutoyé potentiellement voire même
atteinte ou dépasser et je n'aime pas
quand même qu'il y a une évolution
politique qui est en train de se faire
au sein du groupe RDSE je m'en félicite
avec les radicaux de gauche les radicaux
mais avec une majorité manifestement de
sénateurs sénatrice de gauche donc voilà
la gauche renforce oui au Sénat c'est
une bonne surprise la gauche se renforce
sans la France insoumise on précise qui
présentait des candidats partout qui n'a
aucun élu partout et avec d'ailleurs des
professions de foi identiques dans
chaque département ce qui est assez
humiliant pour celles et ceux qui ont
essayé de faire des campagnes de
proximité mais bon la France insoumise
c'est un c'est une pyramide et on sait
que tout vient du haut en la matière
dans tact je pense que ces élections
méritaient mieux de la part de tout le
monde potentiellement mais aussi des
candidats et les filles qui s'était
présentés notamment face à nous ouais
j'ai entendu le mot de rétorsion dans
mon département en prenant une liste en
rétorsion du fait qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'accord avec elle et fille donc mais
globalement 100 et les filles d'abord
dans votre département vous envisiez
trois vous en avez eu deux la faute à
qui la faute à la division de la gauche
non j'ai une dissidence malheureusement
qui m'a coûté ce troisième siège que
j'espérais je le regrette pour Bertrand
ringault que je tiens à saluer qui était
mon troisième dans cette liste le maire
de de Gravelines
elle est fille je crois aurait pu coûter
notamment aux communistes à Eric Bocquet
à Michel gréhomme je suis très content
il s'est réussi à passer malgré cette
cette menace les deux sièges donc la
gauche sort à 4 et on a failli avoir la
France dit la division de la gauche
coûte 10 sièges à la gauche au Sénat
vous attendez quoi c'est faux c'est
strictement faux au contraire nous avons
perdu par exemple un siège en Essonne
s'il y avait pas eu une liste LFI donc
non mais elle est fille voilà est en
train de nous faire un nuage qui n'est
pas la réalité
Christine lavardde la droite et le
centre se maintiennent dans leur
globalité mais les républicains perdent
quelques sièges tandis que les Centris
semblent en gagner quelques-uns quel est
votre réaction est-ce que ça va changer
les équilibres
c'est-à-dire que j'ai regardé hier il y
a quand même un grand nombre de
personnes qui ont été élu divers droites
donc divers droites savoir si les gens
vont sierger au sein du groupe de la
droite au sein du groupe de centres
droits je sais pas vous dire là ce matin
à 8h ce qu'il en est exactement après ce
qui est certain c'est que de nouveau il
y a eu un vote massif pour ce courant de
la droite et du centre droit qui de
toute façon travaille ensemble sur les
différents textes pour porter la voix de
la majorité sénateurs parce que vous
n'avez pas toujours la même voix on va
en parler on va parler notamment de la
loi immigration dans quelques instants
mais pour vous ça va pas rééquilibrer
les choses certains être plutôt pour une
alliance avec Emmanuel Macron alors
les centrices il y a aussi une diversité
décentriste puisque on avait déjà dans
le groupe d'Hervé Marseille des
adhérents du MoDem des adhérents de
l'UDI des adhérents des centristes des
diverses
on voit bien qu'au élections nationales
les centristes sont listes communes avec
les républicains que l'UDI jusqu'à
présent fait liste commune ou avec les
républicains ou liste indépendante quand
le modem donc il y avait déjà cette
diversité qui se traduisait aussi dans
la manière dont le groupe centriste voté
où on avait très rarement un vote massif
de toutes les voies du centriste qui
portait le même choix donc aujourd'hui
le rééquilibrage il va se faire à la
marche plus ou moins un de chaque côté
mais ça va pas changer l'équilibre et la
et la philosophie qui est commune à ces
deux groupes François Patriat on disait
que votre groupe allait perdre des
sénateurs que la majorité présidentielle
vous allez être perdante dans cette
élection ce matin quel bilan vous en
faites vous aviez 24 sénateurs combien
vous en aurez alors dans votre groupe je
peux pas vous le donner alors qu'il est
on verra on verra ce soir plus dedans
déjà la 3 ans pour ma propre élection
tout le monde avait dit que je
reviendrai pas je me souviens là nous
étions 24 nous perdons nous perdons
vraiment parce que vraiment pour des
erreurs te dit nous perdons deux sièges
de façon de manière certaine non mais on
a perdu les Français à l'étranger par
notre propre division c'est dommage on a
perdu un ou deux sièges comme ça par
contre je pense on sera plus de 20 on
sera plus de 20 on était 24 aujourd'hui
je pense qu'à cette heure-ci nous sommes
21 on peut être encore un peu plus de
mal donc on peut pas parler de défaite
de du groupe présidentiel au Sénat qui
qui lui au moins le groupe présidentiel
n'avance pas masqué j'ai eu beaucoup de
sénateurs sans tristes et autres avancer
masquer on est un peu on est dans la
majorité sénatoriale mais on sait
accompagner le gouvernement je pense que
le gouvernement le souhaite aussi puisse
trouver des alliés dans parmi les
centristes il trouvera demain ce que je
regrette à titre personnel c'est que les
modernes ne viennent pas avec nous
pourquoi ils siègent avec les centristes
pour regarder pour avoir des voix des
votes que j'ai vu un petit peu incongru
lors du réforme sur les retraites en
particulier on pourra on pourra reparler
de cela mais ce que je peux dire que la
majorité sénatoriale a travaillé avec
vous bien sûr vous travaillez avec tout
le monde votre nous voulons travailler
avec la droite et avec la gauche on le
verra sur les tests qui vont venir et on
l'a fait par le passé
est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres choix pour
vous que de travailler main dans la main
avec la majorité présidentielle en tout
cas moi ce que je peux dire c'est que
pour avoir assisté à des réunions des
dialogues de Bercy j'ai pu entendre
trois voix différentes mais le
représentant de renaissance le
représentant d'horizon et le
représentant du MoDem qui sur certains
sujets
d'importance ne pense pas du tout la
même chose
donc je suis pas forcément étonnée
qu'aujourd'hui des élus du MoDem siège
dans le groupe de l'Union centriste
puisque aujourd'hui la physionomie du
groupe RDPI du Sénat sont plutôt
d'anciens élus de gauche qui sont passés
au RDPI alors qu'au modem on peut avoir
des idées de droite enfin l'UDF a
toujours été un parti associé à la
droite donc c'est je suis pas étonnée en
fait que le modem ne souhaite pas
rejoindre RPI
sur horizon parce que au sein même de la
majorité présidentielle horizon semble
avoir pris des sièges hier est-ce que là
aussi ça va changer les équilibres
est-ce qu'Edouard Philippe sort renforcé
de cette élection sénateur et l'élection
sénatoriale elle est bien entendu d'une
interprétation politique mais elle est
mécanique
sont trop forcés ça veut dire que c'est
pas des gens qui ont changé de camp ça
veut dire simplement ces gens qui ont
changé l'étiquette je m'explique la
Marne avait avant des députés
républicains à partir de moments
monsieur robinet devient merde devient
horizon et que Reims vote demain horizon
évidemment on est passé d'un député d'un
sénateur républicain assezateur horizon
centrices la dernière fois et un
sénateur LR là on a de nouveau deux LR
et un horizon donc je non mais je veux
dire le cas aujourd'hui c'est il était
le candidat de Monsieur robinet il était
énervant maintenant il est horizon parce
que lui-même est devenu horizon et ça
dans 7 ou 8 départements par ailleurs
donc mécaniquement un ancrage local que
Renaissance n'a pas bien sûr ils sont
dans des territoires où la droite ou qui
les supporte de des élus vous savez
quand vous dit que c'est mécanique pour
organiser des extensions sénatoriales il
faut gagner les élections municipales
manifestement nous n'avons pas gagné
nous avons perdu les élections
municipales donc il y aura un groupe
ingrédient est-ce que vous appelez ce
matin les sénateurs horizons à vous
rejoindre et à siéger au sein du groupe
[Musique]
finalement la respiration démocratique
pour l'oxygénation de nos institutions
moi je préfère cette chambre j'ai connu
autre chambre en tant que ministre en
tant que député comme François moi je
suis je suis heureux de voir que nous
allons pouvoir voir des débats
extrêmement forts sur les sujets de
société on va parler de l'immigration
début novembre et ça permettra aux
Français voilà de se dire mais dans
cette chambre on sait qui est qui face
aux grands problèmes qui nous faut
traiter
le débat de masse sera pas entre la
droite et la gauche je comprends bien
que les républicains les socialistes
d'ailleurs je félicite aujourd'hui mes
deux collègues qui ont été réélus
brillamment d'ailleurs ce qui concerne
mais demain le débat présidentiel il
sera pas entre entre les socialistes et
la républicain il sera entre les
progressistes et les populistes donc je
vous montre aujourd'hui que ni le PS ni
républicains ne peuvent avoir des sports
de gagner de mal à la présidentielle
alors ils peuvent réanimer ton ce qu'ils
veulent le gauche-droite je pense comme
ça je pense comme ça mais ça ne sert pas
ça
le grand écart permanent se faire mal
aux adducteurs politiques en
l'occurrence non je le deuxième tour de
la présidentielle ça a été ça et
justement
un des nouveaux élus du rassemblement
national c'est Christopher jurec qui a
été élu hier soir dans le Pas-de-Calais
bonjour Christopher Zurich merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous avez été
élu hier soir vous faites partie des
trois sénateurs rassemblements national
qui font leur entrée au Sénat vous êtes
de retour au Sénat le rassemblement
national mais avec trois sièges pas de
quoi faire un groupe est-ce que vous
aurez du mal à vous faire entendre
nous on a du mal à vous entendre en
revanche Christopher Zurich on va
essayer de régler on va essayer on va
essayer de régler le petit problème de
son et on va essayer de vous reprendre
dans quelques instants le retour du
rassemblement national au Sénat 3
sénateurs c'est inédit il en avait deux
la dernière fois qu'ils sont arrivés au
Sénat comment vous l'expliquez Patrick
déjà je suis du 59 du Nord
et donc
imaginez imaginer ma tristesse d'avoir
dans le Nord et dans le Pas-de-Calais un
sénateur d'extrême droite parce qu'il
faut appeler un chien un chat et là je
salue le courage d'Alizée bad borne qui
a su nommer les choses
même s'il n'a pas été toujours
accompagné dans ce courage au niveau du
chef de l'État je considère que le RN
malgré de beaux atouts malgré cette
banalisation pour ne pas dire cette
normalisation porte toujours ses images
et cette idéologie de l'exclusion donc
danger le mal continue à progresser je
pèse mes mots et il ne faut pas que
notre pays et les républicains au sens
le plus large du terme s'habitue à cette
forme de normalisation ça nous
interpelle toutes et tous et ça
interpelle aussi les politiques
publiques au niveau de l'État parce que
si des élus des élus des grands
électeurs ont fait confiance à ces
candidats d'extrême droite c'est que
quelque part leur souffrance est
terrible et donc il faut savoir
l'analyser la diagnostiquer et la
combattre on va retrouver Christopher
Zurich Christopher Zurich je sais pas si
vous avez pu entendre Patrick kaner et
sa réaction puisqu'il est sénateur du
Nord un des trois sénateurs du
rassemblement national a été élu dans le
Nord département voisin du vôtre
oui j'ai bien entendu monsieur canard je
suis un peu désolé finalement que
Monsieur kaner soit toujours dans ces
éléments de langage qui à mon avis sont
plus adaptés à l'époque à plus forte
raison que si vous voulez le succès du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui c'est
aussi un peu les chiens du Parti
socialiste je suis désolé de lui dire
aussi franchement aujourd'hui je suis
premier adjoint encore pour quelques
temps de la ville d'Edimbourg ou le
Parti socialiste je pense à jouer un
rôle délétère notamment par l'abandon
des classes populaires aujourd'hui
finalement on joue ce rôle c'est-à-dire
de aussi d'écoute et d'attention auprès
de ceux qui se sentent délaissés qui se
sentent déclassés ça c'est très clair
pour revenir sur votre question tout à
l'heure moi je pense qu'on arrivera à se
faire entendre on a l'expérience si vous
voulez du groupe Parlement de l'avant
groupe parlementaire du RN à l'Assemblée
nationale ou même avec 6 ou 7 députés on
arrivait à bord des certains sujets on
est arrivé à se faire entendre alors oui
on n'avait pas forcément les mêmes
possibilités d'intervention que si on
avait un groupe parlementaire mais on
pouvait au moins servir d'aiguillon
imposer des sujets et au moins
influencer le débat
quel est votre ambition du coup ici au
Sénat Christopher jurec vous qui allez y
faire votre entrée la semaine prochaine
moi si vous voulez mon ambition c'est de
faire ce que j'ai toujours fait dans ma
petite carrière politique c'est d'être
même quand je suis dans l'opposition
d'être respectueux respectable d'être
digne de pas être si vous voulez un
brailleur comme on peut le parfois
l'entendre sur les bandes de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pour ça moi je dis oui
aujourd'hui un monsieur canard ne soyez
pas dans les clichés nous on va on va
être extrêmement respectueux on va faire
des propositions on va pas du tout être
secteur
moi il m'est arrivé vous savez monsieur
canard de voter le budget du Conseil
départemental socialiste du
Pas-de-Calais parce que j'avais trouvé
que c'était un bon budget c'était en
2020 c'était la préco vide il y avait
une nécessité pour la population du
Pas-de-Calais moi quand ça va dans le
sens de l'intérêt des Français je n'ai
aucune difficulté à être dans ce rôle là
non plus je suis pas du tout là si vous
voulez pour dire vulgairement pour
le bordel ça n'est pas du tout
notre ambition et je pense pouvoir
porter la parole aussi de mes deux
collègues demain
oui moi je combat j'ai combattu dans
toute ma vie politique et je combattrai
les idées du Front national même s'il
est devenu le rassemblement national
parce que je pense est un danger pour
notre pays je le ferai respectueux mon
cher collègue je vous rassure nous ne
sommes pas des broyeurs non plus au
groupe socialiste mais nous vous
combattrons parce que nous pensons que
vos solutions ne sont pas les bonnes
pour le pays Christine est-ce que
finalement il n'est pas logique que le
rassemblement national fasse son retour
au Sénat compte tenu de ce qui
représente aujourd'hui dans le pays je
trouve que l'usage de l'adjectif logique
est un peu étrange au regard de ce qu'on
a pu se dire avant parce que sinon dans
votre logique on aurait dû avoir
beaucoup plus de sénateurs élus du parti
la majorité présidentielle on devrait
avoir un nombre équivalent au moins de
sénateurs France insoumises logique
c'est l'adjectif que vous avez employé
donc non c'est pas déballement là c'est
parce que est-ce que c'est pas logique
parce que ce qu'on explique depuis le
début de la matinée c'est que le corps
électoral ce sont des locaux et qu'un
certain nombre de parties qui sont
représentés sur la scène nationale ne
sont pas représentés sur la scène locale
par contre ce que montre cette
dichotomie entre la politique nationale
et la politique locale c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a deux échelles on
raisonne pas de la même manière on ne
vote pas de la même manière quand on
vote pour ses élus de proximité ces mers
c'est conseillers départementaux que
quand on vote pour des élus nationaux
que sont les députés le président de la
République et je pense qu'on le verra
aussi malheureusement au moment des
élections européennes
sauf qu'au-delà des trois sénateurs ils
gagnent des voix le rassemblement
national il gagne des voix des Lulu
locaux est-ce que c'est la preuve qu'ils
sont en train de réussir une forme
d'implantation locale alors ils gagnent
des voix après pour vous dire dans
quelle proportion il gagne ou pas il
faudrait prendre sa calculette et aller
additionner département par département
pour voir la progression par rapport à
2017 après ce que derrière ce il faut
aussi aller regarder à ce moment là des
blancs les nuls pour voir si c'est pas
ceux qui n'ont pas trouvé leur offre
politique par forme un peu de de dépit
ou pour dénoncer ce qui avait pu être
proposé on choisit de glisser un
bulletin rassemblement national enfin ça
ce matin je suis bien incapable de vous
le dire mais voilà il y a une géographie
compliquée quand même ces élections
scrutin indirectes François Patriat
est-ce que l'augmentation des voix du
rassemblement national et l'arrivée de
trois sénateurs rassemblements
nationales ce qui est du jamais vu c'est
un échec d'Emmanuel Macron
d'abord j'entends bien faire porter
Emmanuel Macron tous les échecs de la
terre tous les mots de ce pays c'est
devenu un sport national très répandu
bon ni participez pas je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs ce que je pense c'est d'abord
que les aujourd'hui c'est mécanique
comme je vous le disais à partir du
moment vous avez des élus municipaux
front nationaux j'y ajoute qu'avant il y
avait des mères des pas des petits mères
mais de merde de petites communes qui
n'osaient pas l'avouer qui ne le disait
pas qui pensait Front National qui avait
qui développait les mêmes idées tout
simpliste parfois qui cette fois-ci
s'exprime librement et l'ont fait avec
beaucoup plus de liberté alors quand on
a des élus en Seine-et-Marne vous vous
rendez compte en Seine-et-Marne un élu
Front national en Seine-et-Marne c'est
en dit long sur le territoire qui était
déjà du territoire de Christian Jacob où
il y avait déjà une poussée du
rassemblement national importante elle
se traduit aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont
gagné ils ont gagné des sièges à
l'époque mais entre le discours je
partage de ce que disent mes collègues à
l'instant entre les discours lycées
policés nous sommes là pour aider les
Français dans le malheur du Front
national et le fond leur doctrine qui
reste aujourd'hui on l'a vu puisque
maintenant il reprenne vous avez vu à
bras le corps le problème de
l'immigration la réalité elle est là
chassée naturelle et revient en galop il
reviendra en galop et c'est un danger
pour ce pays un dernier mot Christopher
Zurich vous estimez que vous avez réussi
votre implantation locale du coup
alors de ce point de vue là fatalement
parce qu'à partir du moment où on a 150
grands électeurs cartés rassemblement
national en Pas-de-Calais et que je
finis à 557 voix c'est que fatalement
nos voix nous sommes allés les chercher
ailleurs nous sommes allés chercher dans
la ruralité notamment mais pas que dans
certains conseils municipaux lrps moi
j'ai des élus qui me disent on a voté
pour vous parce qu'on est plus tenu
comme avant par les grandes chapelles
politiques il y a aussi ça qui je pense
beaucoup changé pour venir ce que dit
Madame lavard on a multiplié en moyenne
nos résultats par deux par trois par
départements que ce soit scrutin
majoritaire ou scrutin proportionnaire
sur ces élections
sénatoriales il y a eu une réelle
progression pour autant moi je vous dis
je comprends les éléments de langage de
ce matin qui consiste un petit peu à
tout de suite essayer de dresser une
forme de cordon sanitaire tout ça n'a
plus aucun sens
voilà moi je pense qu'on verra on aura
l'occasion de débattre de tout ça
rapidement mais moi je suis je suis
assez serein sur notre manière notre
capacité à créer le débat on a compris
merci beaucoup je vous remercie d'avoir
été avec nous depuis le Pas-de-Calais un
mot très rapidement il nous reste très
peu de temps puisque vous en parler
François Patriat sur le prochain texte
le texte immigration qui est le prochain
gros texte qui va être examiné au Sénat
hier Emmanuel Macron sur la question des
types de séjour qui est votre ligne
rouge en République il a appelé à sortir
de l'hypocrisie qu'est-ce que vous en
dites alors j'ai cru comprendre en te
les lignes et moi j'avoue je suis plutôt
focalisée sur les chances de demain à
savoir la présentation du projet de loi
de finance qui semblait y avoir une
petite ouverture vers nos demandes mais
je serais bien incapable déjà il faut
arriver à décrypter la parole
présidentielle donc c'est pas toujours
simple mais que voilà il semblait y
avoir une ouverture donc après on va
attendre le compromis vous semble on va
attendre de voir ce qui est écrit
c'est-à-dire ce que sur tout un tas de
sujets il y a les déclarations du
président de la République puis ensuite
on voit ce qui est écrit dans le projet
de loi qui nous est soumis vous êtes
optimiste sur un compromis François
patron le président de la République n'a
jamais dit que l'attribution de titre de
séjour était automatique et irréversible
hier soir on leur découvre moi je l'ai
entendu dire par les collaborateurs du
Président Paul batteur la première
ministre depuis des semaines c'est cette
possibilité qui est offerte de pouvoir
demain donner des papiers à des immigrés
aujourd'hui qui vont qui vont occuper
des emplois dans les Français ne veulent
pas aujourd'hui mais intime ni
automatique ni réversible une discussion
vous semble possible pas être les canard
est-ce que à certaines conditions
pourriez le voter ce texte écoutez nous
nous allons étudier de très près la
première partie la partie de la
régularisation même si ce mot voilà est
très très rarement utilisé par les
tenants de la majorité
présidentielle c'est important de donner
une perspective à tous ces personnes qui
aujourd'hui font tourner aussi en partie
l'économie française pour le reste nous
verrons bien je pense que la droite va
vraiment droitiser au Sénat elle est
majoritaire ce texte donc dans ce cadre
là nous prenons nos responsabilités je
crois que la vraie danger c'est le 49-3
je me demande si on ne va pas y passer
comme sur beaucoup d'autres textes
malheureusement et ça c'est un danger
pour nos institutions merci on aura
l'occasion d'en débattre le texte qui
devrait arriver au Sénat début novembre
merci merci François patriar merci
Christine la